bonjour à tous ravi de vous retrouver
sur Public Sénat le 23 juin les
Britanniques ont décidé de quitter
l'Union européenne un choc un séisme car
aucun pays de l'Union ne s'était jamais
prononcé pour une sortie avant cela un
séisme car personne ne mesure encore les
conséquences téluriques d'un tel
événement quelles seront justement les
conséquences pour le projet européen et
bien le Gouvernement a souhaité faire
une déclaration devant les sénateurs
avant un débat c'est ce que je vous
propose d'écouter aujourd'hui on a tout
d'abord pu entendre Jean-Marc kraud le
ministre des Affaires étrangères qui a
défendu la position officielle de la
France la position d'une sortie du
Royaume-Uni la plus rapide possible et
puis après Jean-Marc ho c'est un
Jean-Pierre rafarin particulièrement
lyrique particulièrement grave qui a
pris la parole je vous propose donc de
suivre tout de suite suite ces débats et
ces déclarations mesdames messieurs les
ministres mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs dans le cadre de l'article 50
alinéa 1 de la Constitution j'ai
l'honneur de vous présenter
l'intervention que le premier ministre
est actuellement en train de faire à
l'Assemblée nationale mesdames messieurs
les sénateurs le choc est historique
pour la première fois depuis le début de
la construction européenne un peuple a
décidé de quitter ion on croit toujours
les choses acquises que ce qui a été
fait ne peut-être
défait combien de fois avons-nous
entendu parler de
l'irréversibilité de la construction
européenne les Britanniques se sont donc
prononcer il faut respecter ce choix
démocratique il s'impose à nous tous dès
lors l'alternative l'alternative est
simple soit on fait comme toujours en
évitant l'évidence en essayant
simplement de colmater les brèches avec
de petits arrangements soit nous prenons
enfin notre courage à à de mains et nous
allons au fond des choses nous faisons
de ce choc un
électrochoc car l'erreur historique
serait de croire que ce référendum ne
regarde que les
Britanniques non c'est de l'avenir de
chacun des peuples de l'Union qui s'agit
donc aussi et avant tout celui du peuple
français c'est pourquoi le gouvernement
a souhaité venir s'exprimer devant vous
en plein accord avec le président de
votre
assemblée parce que je crois
profondément à l'Europe je refuse que ce
grand dessin
dérive je refuse qu'il chavire et sombre
entraîné par le poids grandissant des
populismes je refuse que nous cédions au
fatalisme au pessimisme je refuse que
nous subissions pour cela chacun doit
s'interroger
et surtout réinterroger ses
certitudes savoir se remettre en
question je sais bien que certains
diront que le résultat de ce référendum
n'est pas surprenant après tout le
Royaume-Uni a toujours eu une relation
particulière à l'Europe un pied dedans
un pied dehors comme on a coutume
parfois de le dire le vote de jeudi
révèle sans doute et même certainement
quelque chose de beaucoup plus profond
ce vote montre aussi le malais
pe qui doutent de l'Europe qui ne
comprennent pas toujours ce qu'elle fait
ne voi pas aussi ce que le apporte
concrètement et pour eu l'Europe devient
envahissante sur l'accessoire et absente
sur l'essentiel pire le sentiment
qu'elle impose ses choix et joue contre
ses
intérêts pendant la
campagne du référendum en
Grande-Bretagne le slogan des pro brexit
reprendre le pouvoir et dit au fond
clairement les
choses même si on connaît les raisons de
ce slogan l'usage qui en a été fait et
les conséquences pour autant on ne peut
l'ignorer l'Europe se fera avec les
peuples sinon elle se disloquera et la
France doit être à
l'initiative justement après ce constat
que faut-il faire ma conviction c'est
que cette crise comme toutes les crises
est l'occasion d'une grande
transformation comme au cours de ces
dernières années chaque fois que
l'essentiel est en jeu sur l'Europe la
France se doit de répondre présente
c'était vrai il y a un an lorsqu'il a
fallu sauver la Grèce et convaincre nos
partenaires qu'elle devait rester dans
la zone euro je n'oublie pas que
certains voulaient sceller le destin de
ce grand pays d'un revers de main
certains vou V faire sortir un pays
membre oubliant le principe même de
solidarité et la suite des événements
leur a donné tort même si tout n'a pas
été réglé ce pays aujourd'hui se porte
mieux et en est notamment reconnaissant
à la France sauver la Grèce c'était déjà
sauvé l'Europe et il y a un an la France
par la voix du chef de l'État était dans
son rôle et elle le sera une nouvelle
fois
aujourd'hui parce que nous sommes la
France un pays respecté écouté attendu
mais parce que nous sommes aussi et
c'est une responsabilité politique et
morale un pays fondateur de l'Europe
parce qu'avec l'Allemagne conscient de
nos responsabilités nous voulons
l'Europe notre horizon commun le
président de la République l'a rappelé
hier soir avec la chancellière allemande
et le président du Conseil italien parce
que nous savons que c'est l'union qui
nous renforce et la désunion qui nous
affaiblit je mets en garde ceux qui croi
qu'on renforcera notre souveraineté
nationale en tirant un trait sur
l'Europe ceux qui pensent qu'on s'en
sortira mieux dans la mondialisation
qu'on traitera mieux la crise migratoire
qu'on combattra mieux le terrorisme en
agissant seul en se privant d'appui dans
le sol cadre de nos frontières
nationales rien n'est plus faux être
européen aujourd'hui et demain c'est
respecter le choix des peuples et c'est
aussi vouloir peser sur le cours des
chos et chacun se rappelle de ces mots
de François mitteran la France est notre
patrie l'Europe notre avenir et donc
être européen ce n'est pas trahir la
France c'est en contraire l'aimer et la
protéger depuis plusieurs jours le
président François Hollande est à
l'initiative il a d'abord souhaité
rencontrer les présidents des deux
assemblées puis les chefs des formations
politiques représenté au Parlement
français et au Parlement européen il
s'est ensuite entretenu avec le
président du Conseil européen et du
Parlement européen puis avec la
chancelière allemande le président du
Conseil italien et nombre de ses
homologues en ce qui me concerne et avec
arlem désir dès le 24 juin j'ai
participé au Conseil des affaires
générales à Luxembourg où était présent
les 28 dont la Grande-Bretagne j'étais
le lendemain à Berlin à la réunion des
pays fondateurs hier à Prague avec le
groupe de vaisscarad avec le secrétaire
d'État aux Affaires européennes je le
disais nous avons multiplié les contacts
et nous continuons j'aurais dit ce soir
eu au téléphone chaque ministre des
Affaires étrangères des 27 et cet
échange est attendu il est essentiel
comme j'ai eu un échange aussi ce matin
avec le secrétaire général de l'OTAN
Jeff Stoltenberg le chef de l'État comme
vous le savez est aujourd'hui au Conseil
européen il le sera demain et il y
tiendra un discours de fermeté vis-à-vis
des Britanniques non pas que nous
voudrions les punir ce serait absurde et
irrespectueux vis-à-vis d'un grand
peuple la Grande-Bretagne le Royaume-Uni
restera un grand pays amis à qui nous
devons TS dans 3 jours nous célébrerons
ensemble centenaire de la bataille de la
somme et nous continuerons de coopérer
en particulier en matière de défense de
gestion migratoire et sur le plan
économique mais l'Europe
elle a aussi besoin de
clarté soit on décide d'en
sortir soit on reste dans l'Union et je
comprends que le Royaume-Uni veuille
défendre ses intérêts mais l'Europe doit
aussi se battre pour les sien depuis
janvier 2013 elle est suspendue à la
décision
britannique nous avons ont fait preuve
de patience de compréhension
d'orénavant entre deux l'ambigués ne
sont plus possibles parce que nous avons
besoin de stabilité notamment sur les
marchés financiers ce n'est pas au
partis conservateur d'imposer son agenda
soyons clair comme le Parlement européen
l'a demandé ce matin le Royaume-Uni doit
activer le plus tôt possible la clause
de retrait de l'Union européenne prévu
dans le traité de Lisbonne pour éviter à
chacun une incertitude qui serait
préjudiciable et protéger l'intégrité du
de l'Union je cite le texte il n'y a pas
de temps à perdre il s'agit de l'article
50 et tant que l'article 50 ne sera pas
déclenché et bien les Britanniques ne
pourront se prévaloir d'un accès au
marché unique il faudra alors respecter
l'intégralité des règles c'est-à-dire
d'un membre à part entière de l'Union
européenne avec ses droits et ses
devoirs donc je le disais le président
de la République au nom de la France
tiendra un langage de fermeté mais aussi
un langage de vérité car il faut
réinventer et vous inventer une nouvelle
Europe inventer c'est-à-dire passer à
une nouvelle grande étape il y a eu la
reconstruction après la Seconde Guerre
mondiale puis pendant la guerre froide
la consolidation et l'élargissement nous
avons accueilli de jeunes démocraties je
pense à la Grèce l'Espagne Portugal
après la chute du Mur nous avons œuvré à
la réunification du continent les acquis
historiques de la construction
européenne à laquelle la France a
toujours pris une part essentielle sont
irremplaçables et la France est garante
du maintien de ses acquis malgré la paix
malgré les formidables échanges
économiques et culturels malgré la
création d'une monnaie unique à laquelle
les Français sont attachés une fracture
s'est ouverte elle n'a cessé de grandir
elle a des causes profondes ce n'est pas
uniquement une question de norme
tatillon c'est a question de
souveraineté démocratique et d'identité
car les peuples ont l'impression que
l'Europe veut diluer ce qu'ils sont et
que des siècles d'histoire ont façonné
or une Europe qui nirait les nations
ferait simplement le lit des
nationalismes ce modèle au-dessus des
nations niant la particularité de chacun
serait un échec et certains ont laissé
croire qu'il était le seul possible
question de souveraineté et de
démocratie aussi nous avons cru pouvoir
agrandir à marche au forcé que les noms
seruraient oubliés grâce à plus d'Europe
que les référendums pourraient être
contourné que le rejet croissant de
l'Europe se soignait uniquement par de
la pédagogie avons-le depuis 2005 nous
avons fui les vrais débats et nous avons
laissé un boulevard à ceux qui
exploitaient le malaise nous avons
laissé les populismes proférés leurs
mensonges et installer l'idée que
construction européenne et souveraineté
nationale était
incompatible nous devons reprendre la
main retrouver les sources de l'adhésion
au projet européens et surtout
réinventer les causes de l'adhésion en
répondant à ces questions pourquoi
sommes-nous européens quel est notre
projet collectif quel intérêt avons-nous
à être ensemble pour défendre quelle
valeur l'Europe c'est une culture c'est
une histoire commune c'est la démocratie
c'est le continent de la conquête des
libertés ce sont des valeurs partagées
l'égalité entre les femmes et les hommes
une exigence quant à la dignité de la
personne c'est l'aspiration à
l'universalité la défense de la nature
et de la planète et un certain modèle du
vivre ensemble et de cohésion sociale
oui chacun de nos pays a ses propres
caractéristiques mais seule une union
peut les protéger face à la concurrence
de pays continents l'Europe c'est notre
interface avec le monde elle doit être
une protection quand nous en avons
besoin elle doit être aussi l'occasion
de démultiplier nos forces nous
permettre de peser plus que si nous
étions
seuls tout cela c'est le sens des
initiatives que la France entend porter
d'abord en mettant en jeu en les enjeux
de sécurité au cœur de l'Union la menace
terroriste la crise migratoire mettre
l'espace Schengen à l'épreuve nous
devons en reprendre le contrôle
dans un monde dangereux si l'Europe ne
protège pas alors elle ne joue pas son
rôle grâce à la France beaucoup a déjà
été fait le PNR européen enfin
l'encadrement de la circulation des
armes mais il faut aller plus loin et
vraiment maîtriser nos frontières
extérieures pas en sortant de Schengen
mais en agissant pour que les règles
régissant cet espace soi appliqué
fermement et pleinement oui l'Europe a
des frontières une frontière ce n'est
pas pas seulement une réalité matérielle
géographique c'est aussi une réalité
symbolique qui nous définit qui dit ce
que nous sommes et ce que nous ne sommes
pas qui dit où l'Europe commence et où
elle s'arrête l'Europe ce n'est pas un
ensemble
indéfini l'Europe doit également assumer
un effort de défense digne de ce nom et
être capable d'intervenir à l'extérieur
et ce d'autant plus que les États-Unis
se désengagent de plus en plus il ne
faut donc plus hésiter c'est d'abord
cela que la France entendemportter
auprès de ses partenaires l'Europe de
demain doit être protectrice et puis
l'Europe doit mieux s'imposer en
protégeant l'intérêt des
Européens C son une forme de naïveté les
états-tiers comme la Chine l'Inde ou les
États-Unis défendent bec et ongle leurs
intérêts partout dans le monde et nous
nous ne le ferions pas alors changeons
d'état d'esprit dans tous les domaines
économiques industriel financier
commercial agricole avec notamment la
filière laitière mais aussi culturelle
environnementale sociale
l'Europe ne doit plus être perçu comme
le cheval de tro de la mondialisation
elle doit protéger ses intérêts ses
travailleurs ses entreprise je pense par
exemple au secteur de l'acier qui
représente des milliers d'emplois en
France et en Europe nous devons faire
preuve de la même fermeté par la la
négociation du Traité du tafta il faut
dire les choses ce texte aujourd'hui ne
fait droit à aucune de nos demandes que
ce soit sur l'accès au marchés publics
sur les indications géographiques elle
est donc pas acceptable nous ne pouvons
pas ouvrir plus grand les portes de
notre marché aux entreprises américaine
alors que elle continue à barrer l'accès
au nôtre mesdames messieurs les
sénateurs l'Europe c'est 8% de
population mondiale et pour conserver
son rang faire entendre sa voix peser
face aux grands ensembles bâtir une
relation forte avec l'Afrique ce
continent d'avenir défendre son
exception culturelle elle doit
s'affirmer comme la puissance qu'elle
est en s'en donnant tous les moyens
l'Europe le président de la République
l'a dit en des termes très fort des
vendredis doit être une puissance qui
décide souverainement de son destin pour
cela est doit investir massivement pour
la croissance et pour l'emploi bâtir une
stratégie industrielle dans les
nouvelles technologies et la transition
énergétique le plan Junker est d'ors et
déjà un succès rien qu'en France il a
permis de financer qure
4,5 milliards d'euros de projet mais il
faut poursuivre et notamment poursuivre
l'harmonisation fiscal et social et cela
par le haut pour donner à nos économies
des règles et à nos concitoyens des
garanties certains disent que c'est
impossible mais enfin ce que nous avons
réussi pour le secret bancaire pour un
socle commun des droits sociaux nous
pouvons aussi le faire contre toutes les
formes de dumping qui rongent le projet
européen de l'intérieur avec la mise en
place d'un salaire minimum avec la lutte
contre la fraude au détachement des
travailleurs cette fraude c'est
s'asseoir sur les règles les plus
fondamentales des droits des salariés
rémunération temps de travail
hébergement et l'Europe resterait
impuissante non si on ne le fait pas
c'est un des piliers du du traité de
Rome la libre circulation des
travailleurs qui sera balayée c'est
pourquoi il faut modifier en profondeur
la directive de
1996 la commission l'a proposé à nous de
l'adopter
enfin nous devons renforcer la zone euro
et sa gouvernance
démocratique dès le discours de
politique générale en avril
2014 j'avais demandé une BCE plus active
beaucoup a été fait le plus souvent à
l'initiative de la France la zone euro
est plus puissante et résistance qu'en
2008 mais il doit y avoir plus de
convergence entre les États-membres et
plus de légitimité dans les décisions
pris c'est pourquoi il faut à la fois un
budget et un parlement de la zone euro
alors avec quelle méthode il faut
réinventer l'Europe il faut aussi une
nouvelle manière de faire l'Europe en
donnant le sentiment d'intervenir
partout tout le temps l'Europe s'est
affaiblie elle doit être offensive là où
son efficacité est utile mais elle doit
savoir s'effacer quand les compétences
doivent rester au niveau national voire
régional le président Junker en est
convaincu en affirmant le principe de la
subsidiarité mais cette nouvelle
philosophie est loin d'avoir pénétré
tous les esprits à Bruxelles mesdames
messieurs les sénateurs il est grand
temps de dépasser les oppositions
stériles l'Europe ce n'est pas la fin
des états c'est l'exercice commun en
commun des souverainetés nationales
lorsque c'est plus efficace et lorsque
les peuples choisissent et comme l'avait
déjà dit Jacques Delor en son temps
l'Europe est et doit être une fédération
d'État nation un exemple si la France
s'est batue pour une mise en œuvre
rapide des gardes aux frontières c'est
parce que nous savons que la
souveraineté de notre pays que la
maîtrise opérationnelle de de notre
frontière doit commencer à Lesbos ou à
Lampedusa il faut aussi une Europe qui
décide vite et qui sait le faire lorsque
comme l'ont montré les négociations un
temp record du plan Junker s'il faut
mener à quelques-uns ce que les 27 ne
sont pas prêts à faire alors faisonsle
sortons des dogmes l'Europe ce n'est pas
l'uniformité il y a des différences
enfin le débat démocratique européen
doit impérativement gagner en qualité
c'est aussi une leçon du scrutin
britannique à force de ne pas parler
d'Europe les populistes n'ont aucune
difficulté à raconter n'importe quoi à
tromper et c'est grave pour l'Europe et
c'est fatal pour la démocratie l'Europe
ça ne peut pas être simplement les États
qui rendent des comptes sur la gestion
de leur budget bien sûr il faut des
règles la France les respecte mais
attention à cette image d'une Europe
punitive acquise aux thèses
ultralibérales et à l'austérité
budgétaire c'est cela que nos
concitoyens rejettent et ils ne
comprendrai pas si le seul message de la
Commission dans les prochains jours
était de sanctionner l'Espagne et le
Portugal et la
nation c'est aussi sa représentation
nationale elle doit avoir son mot à dire
je souhaite donc que les inst
dont les je souhaite donc que les
instances européennes puissent rendre
beaucoup plus compte de leur action
devant les parlements nationaux que les
commissaires eux-mêmes viennent devant
vous s'expliquer et je sais Monsieur le
Président puisque vous l'avez dit dans
votre entretien avec le Président de la
République que vous souhaitez que le
Sénat saisisse pleinement les
instruments de contrôle que l'Europe met
à votre disposition le gouvernement
souhaite bien évidemment associer au
maximum le Parlement à ces questions et
se tient monsieur le Président à la
disposition du Sénat pour toutes les
initiatives que vous seriez amené à
prendre il faut un changement de culture
Les Affaires européennes sont des
affaires intérieures beaucoup de
propositions sont sur la table certains
suggèrent une convention une commission
un travail avec des sages certains
nonont que le mot référendum à la bouche
bien sûr il faut donner la parole au
peuple et le peuple français l'aura dans
quelques mois mais soyons clair
un référendum ne peut pas être le moyen
de se débarrasser d'un problème encore
moins un moyen de régler des problèmes
de politique interne on a vu ce que cela
donnait quand on jouait aux apprentis
sorciers en Grande-Bretagne je veux être
encore plus clair par le
référendum puisque je le cite volontiers
le Front national ne poursuit au fond
qu'un seul objectif qui est désormais
dévoilé faire sortir la France de
l'Union européenne et donc sa propre
histoire et de son propre destin quelle
triste ambition pour un parti qui se
prétend patriote mesdames et messieurs
les
sénateurs notre rôle notre rôle de
responsable politique n'est pas de
suivre mais d'éclairer de montrer le
chemin la question qui se pose à la
France n'est pas de sortir de l'Europe
mais de refonder le projet européen et
je le dis le projet l'élection
présidentielle sera le moment privilégié
pour les citoyens de trancher ces débats
mais je crois que dans ce moment il faut
également inventer des solutions
nouvelles pour une
construction avec les peuples autour de
projets de proposition je pense à
l'exemple de la COP 21 qui a été
particulièrement enrichissant en terme
de
méthode et j'ajouterai aussi que la COP
21 et le bon exemple pour ceux qui
prétendent défendre des intérêts de la
nation que si nous avions négocié tout
seul la France à l'échelle
internationale un accord pour le climat
croyez-vous que nous aurions été plus
fort qu'à 28 la démonstration est faite
que c'est parce que nous avons négocié à
28 que la France avec l'Europe a
pesé mesdames messieurs les sénateurs je
conclus en rappelant qu'il faut bien sûr
les citoyens
davantage les parlements nationaux et
européens ont leur rôle à jouer les
parlements nationaux et donc vous-même
devront se prononcer sur le libre
échange le traité de libre échange entre
l'Union européenne et le Canada vous le
savez il y a un débat certains
voudraient que seul le Parlement
européen se prononce la position de la
France est très clair c'est les deux
parlements les parlements nationaux et
le Parlement européen qui son se
prononceront il n'y a pas d'autre voix
possible mesdames messieurs les
sénateurs il y a l'urgence à laquelle
l'Europe doit faire face dès aujourd'hui
c'est créer les conditions les
meilleures pour négocier dans le casadre
de l'article 50 du traité européen la
sortie du Royaume Uni de l'Union
européenne mais c'est aussi de préparer
l'avenir c'est notre responsabilité
commune merci mesdames messieurs les
sénateurs d'y contribuer par vos débats
et vos intervention
merci merci monsieur le
ministre des Affaires
étrangères la parole est maintenant au
président de la commission des affaires
étrangères de la défense et des forces
armées Monsieur Jean-Pierre
affarin monsieur le Président Monsieur
le Ministre d'affaires étrangères
mesdames messieurs les ministres
mes chers
collègues pour un
Européen le brexit a d'abord été une
immense tristesse et aussi une profonde
inquiétude mais au total nous impose une
nécessaire
détermination une profonde tristesse de
voir l'actualité bousculer l'histoire de
mesurer le rejet
du bilan de l'Europe combien de
marathons combien de sommet combien de
bilatéral combien de séances du
Parlement européen combien de tout
petits pas fait par des très grands
hommes tout ça a été rejeté il y a
depuis deux générations des centaines et
des centaines de dirigeants européens
qui se sont impliqués et voilà les
erreurs ont condamné les acquis et nous
sommes face à une réalité aujourd'hui
inquiétante la déconstruction de
l'Europe est-elle engagée d'évidence mes
chers collègues l'affaiblissement de
l'Europe ce n'est pas le moment ce n'est
pas le moment où tous les continents
sont en train de s'organiser ce n'est
pas le moment où des pays continents la
Chine l'Inde les États-Unis le Brésil et
beaucoup d'autres et les pays émergents
de l'Afrique sont en train d'essayer de
diriger la gouvernance du monde c'est au
moment où les pays continents assument
leur responsabilité dans le monde que
nous européens nous choisissons la voie
de la déconstruction et plus grave
peut-être encore croyez-vous que notre
ennemi numéro 1 le terrorisme ne se
réjouisse pas de nous voir aujourd'hui
affaibli fragilisé ce n'est vraiment pas
le moment d'affaiblir notre continent ce
n'est pas le moment de nous diviser nous
le savons bien la force passe
nécessairement par le rassemblement si
l'Europe est mortel chers amis ça veut
dire que la guerre n'est pas impossible
c'est ça la vérité qui est devant nous
aujourd'hui si l'Europe est mortelle la
guerre n'est plus impossible alors
quelles sont les responsabilités bien
évidemment n'accusons pas le peuple
anglais la démocratie aussi est très
fragile nous le voyons ici même les
Européens les
proeuropéens ceux parmi lesquels je me
sens ces Européens ne sont pas innocents
de ce malaise ils n'ont pas su ni
réformer ni convaincre la réalité pour
les peuples c'est que Lisbonne n'a pas
changé mastrich et si nous sommes
aujourd'hui dans cette réalité c'est
qu'au fond malgré les efforts les
réformes constitutionnelles que nous
avons inventé quand on a décidé de faire
en sorte que le président de la
Commission soit nommé par le Parlement
comme beaucoup de de Premier ministre le
sont dans l'Union européenne cela n'a
pas suffi pour convaincre l'opinion
publique que la construction européenne
avait des fondements démocratiques dans
cette situation comme disait saintex il
ne faut pas être responsable et
désespéré puisque nous sommes
responsables il nous faut être déterminé
pour engager cette
refondation il faut le faire sans perdre
de temps vous l'avez dit monsieur le
ministre il faut aller vite quelles sont
les nécessités de la refondation d'abord
choisir le langage de la vérité il y a
beaucoup de mensonge sur l'Europe le
premier mensonge des responsables
politiques partout dans l'Union
européenne c'est de ne pas assumer
l'Europe c'est nous l'Europe c'est pas
les autres et quand un ministre de
l'Agriculture perd un arbitrage ce n'est
pas la faute des arbitre c'est la faute
de nos propres responsabilités et ça
c'est vrai pour la droite comme pour la
gauche l'Europe c'est nous et quand on
négocie mal la l'organisation par
exemple de la direction générale de
l'agriculture à Bruxelles il faut pas
s'étonné qu'ensuite on puisse perdre des
arbitrages en matière agricole mais ça
c'est une responsabilité qui est une
responsabilité politique n'allons pas
chercher les technocrates n'allons pas
chercher la bureaucratie la bureaucratie
ce n'est que l'expression de la
faiblesse de la politique et l'Europe
elle n'est pas assumée par les
politiques et c'est une responsabilité
collective assumons cette construction
européenne c'est une première vérité
l'Europe c'est nous deuxè vérité
l'élargissement dans cette situation
nous est
interdit nous ne pouvons pas aujourd'hui
élargir l'Europe dans la situation
d'affaiblissement dans laquelle nous
nous trouvons alors cessons de faire
rêver la Turquie à une éventuelle
adhésion à l'Union européenne
non l'urut pas s'élargir non l'Europe
doit se conforter non l'Europe
aujourd'hui doit penser à l'intérieur de
ces frones à une vie organisée
harmonieuse avant de penser à quelqu
élargissement que ce soit trisème
contevérité l'EUR n'est pas fédérale
c'est une coopérative et le pouvoir en
Europe n'est pas celui qui a la plus
grande créativité n'est pas celui qui va
imaginer la plus grande proposition le
pouvoir est à celui qui est capable de
faire partager par les autres ses
propres propositions c'est pas un
pouvoir déclaratif c'est un pouvoir
d'influence là est le talent savoir
rassembler c'est cela ce langage de
vérité qu'il nous faut tenir et donc il
faut pas dire je vais à Bruxelles pour
tenir un discours ceci ou cela non
qu'est-ce que disent les Allemands
qu'est-ce que disent les Italiens
qu'est-ce que disent les autres
qu'est-ce que vous avez fait pour
convaincre c'est cette capacité- là qui
est celle qui offre un véritable levier
pour faire bouger l'Europe quelle est
notre vision de l'Europe je crois qu'au
fond dans ce pays apparaît assez
clairement à la suite de nombreux débats
encore faudrait-il peut-être
l'approfondir ce débat mais apparaît une
vision assez claire on pourrait appeler
ça l'Europe des sercles et des piliers
conclure l'Europe des cercles et des
piliers les cercles c'est l'Europe des
trois espaces le cercle des fondateurs
le cercle de l'euro le cercle de la
Grande Europe avec les grands
partenaires comme la Russie ou la
Turquie c'est-à-dire une Europe du
voisinage mais le cercle de l'euro celui
qui est le plus coopératif et monsieur
le Président toutes ces visions là d'une
Europe qui serait une Europe espace en
trois cercles mais d'une Europe
puissance avec des compétences définies
en fonction de priorités et tout ce qui
n'est pas dans les priorités renvoyé à
l'État nation c'est cela le aujourd'hui
ce principe de subsidiarité qu'il faut
pouvoir
révoquer si tout cela est possible il y
a un chemin à prendre ce chemin il est à
prendre avec les Allemands à la fois
naturellement pour partager une vision
et à la fois monsieur le Président pour
pouvoir faire en sorte que nous ayons
nous-mêmes un rapport franco-allemand
qui ne soit pas celui de la vacuité mais
qui soit au contraire celui de
l'imagination et pour
terminer excusez-moi mais je vous
permets de vous citer
un le plus européen de tous les pictau
charanta C Jean monony qui disait ce qui
est le important aujourd'hui ce n'est
pas d'être optimiste ce n'est pas d'être
pessimiste c'est d'être
déterminé
merci merci pour la détermination la
parole est maintenant au président Jean
biset président de la commission pour
l'Union européenne du Sénat
merci
monsieur le
Président Monsieur le Ministre des
Affaires étrangère et du développement
international mesdames Messieurs chers
amis le peuple britannique a donc choisi
la sortie de l'Union européenne ce
résultat est un choc pour tous ceux qui
croient en l'ID européenne il démontre
cruellement le manque d'un leadership
européen marqué notamment par la
faiblesse du couple
franco-allemand le RoyaumeUni se prépare
ainsi un difficile chemin il devra
maintenir sa cohésion en en surmontant
la fracture générationnelle et
territoriale que révèle le scrutin du 23
juin il devra négocier les termes d'un
partenariat avec l'Union européenne dans
un nouveau statut qui sera celui d'un
pays tiers l'Union doit engager
rapidement cette négociation dont le
déclochement relève de de la
Grande-Bretagne et d'elle seu elle ne
doit pas être l'otage des débats
politiques internes à un pays qui a
choisi de la quité elle doit travailler
un partenariat nouveau qui puisse
fonctionner correctement à partir d'un
terrain commun d'intérêt commun bien
identifié tirons nous aussi tous les
enseignements du vote du 23 juin en
clair il faut refonder l'Union
européenne sur de nouvelles bases la
sortie du Royaume-Uni rend cette
exigence d'autant plus
forte il est donc désormais urgent
d'adresser quatre messages essentiels au
peuple européen premier message mettre
un frein comme l'a dit tout à l'heure le
président rafarin mettre un frein à
l'élargissement et sécuriser
concrètement les frontières nous voulons
un Schengen de 2e génération qui assure
cette sécurité et n'hésite pas à
suspendre les états défaillants nous
devons construire des partenariats
efficaces au sud avec la Turquie sur la
question migratoire à l'est avec la
Russie en valorisant nos intérêt
économique réciproque second message
recentrer l'Europe autour d'un noyau dur
ouvert d'État membre déterminé à aller
de l'avant le couple franco-allemand
doit en être le moteur il est
malheureusement aujourd'hui en panne il
est impératif de le relancer nos deux
pays doivent précisément montrer la VO
en construisant l'union de l'énergie par
la mutualisation des coûts et le partage
des réseaux en bâtissant le marché
unique du numérique avec une Europe
productrice et pas seulement
consommatrice en affirmant l'ingénierie
financière européenne la City avouons-le
étant désormais hors de l'union et ceci
à partir de l'excellence des places de
Paris et Francfort trè message
mettre en œuvre les priorités
stratégiques innovantes du plan
Junker l'industrie créatrice de richesse
et d'emploi l'énergie qui est une
composante fondamentale pour notre
compétitivité et le numérique qui est
précisément au cœur de toute activité du
21e siècle c'est une c'est une union
centrée sur l'essentiel dont nous avons
besoin la relance de l'investissement
doit être une priorité nous avons
carrément besoin n'ayons pas peur des
mots d'un fond souverain européen qui
serait tout simplement le fond juncur de
2e
génération nous devons bâtir une
nouvelle politique commune en intégrant
la nouvelle géopolitique alimentaire
qu'elle peut justement comporter enfin
le 4èe message il faut redonner aux
parlements nationaux toute l'attitude de
décider des normes relatives la vie
quotidienne de nos concitoyens en
affirmant le principe de subsidiarité en
faisant de la simplification le fil
directeur de notre action
commune dans un monde globalisé face à
des états de vrais états continents les
replis nationaux ne sont pas la bonne
réponse nous voulons une Europe
puissance qui s'affirme sur la scène
internationale cette Europe puissance
doit se doter d'une capacité de
au sens propre et figuré elle doit
négocier des accords commerciaux sur la
base d'un CAH des charges précis je
dirais exanté ce qui relativise la
pertinence du concept du traité mix
puisque précisément ils seront négociés
au
préalable les parlements nationaux
devant pouvoir en débattre et fixer des
lignes rouges précisément dès le départ
ne restons pas enfin sans réagir face à
l'extraterritorialité des lois
américaines contraire au droit
international utilisons tous nos
instruments de défense opposons un bail
europeéan Act au bail amerriican Act si
nos partenaires commerciaux ne
respectent pas leurs engagements alors
appliquons des clauses de sauvegarde
pour préserver nos intérêts et ceci avec
rapidité mesdames Messieurs mes chers
collègues l'histoire au travers du
brexit vient de nous vient de donner une
nouvelle chance à l'Europe
saisissonsla réinventons l'Europe
réenchantons l'Europe à défaut elle
sortira de l'histoire et la France avec
je vous remercie merci monsieur le
Président dans la suite de notre débat
la parole est aux orateurs des groupes
et d'abord le président Didier Guillaume
pour le groupe socialiste et républicain
et pour 10 minutes
vous avez la parole monsieur le
Président merci monsieur le président
monsieur le ministre des Affaires
étrangères mesdames et messieurs les
ministres mes chers collègues c'est la
4è fois en un an que nous nous
retrouvons ici en débat dans cette
hémicycle après une déclaration du
gouvernement sur un sujet européen on
pourrait s'en réjouir et se dire qu'il y
a une poussée d'intérêt pour l'Europe
mais force de constater que si c avait
été ça ça aurait été heureux la
multiplication l'accélération des crises
dans notre union
continentale nous amène à nouveau
aujourd'hui à discuter et à débattre
après la crise de l'euro et l'action
pour faire rester la Grèce dans l'euro
et je veux saluer l'action du Président
de la République François Hollande et du
gouvernement français qui ont
contribuer alors que certains à l'époque
voulaient le grexit
la France a toujours dit non la place de
la Grèce est dans l'Europe et dans
l'euro après la recherche d'une solution
sur les réfugiés et il y a encore
beaucoup de travail nous voici
aujourd'hui confronté à une première
historique pour l'Europe un divorce
entre notre communauté européenne et
l'un de ses membres cette nouvelle
difficulté sans doute la plus ardue et
il faut la surmonter c'est de notre
ibilité collective à nous les Français à
nous les Européens à la France et à tous
les pays d'Europe oui cette rupture mes
chers collègu ne vient pas de nulle part
peu la formulé avant la convocation du
référendum britannique mais beaucoup la
craignaiit beaucoup pensaient que cela
allait arriver et voilà nous y sommes
cette rupture entre l'Europe et l'un de
ces peuple intervient comme le point
d'org je le disais à l'instant d'une
multiplication des crises EUR euréne
bien sûr il a eu la crise économique qui
a entraîné dans son sillage la crise des
dettes souveraines après 2008 mais les
difficultés de l'Europe avec les peuples
avaient commencé bien avant de la peur
de davantage d'intégration dans les
années 90 à la crainte d'un projet trop
vertical en 2005 les signes de défiance
des peuples envers l'Europe étaient
nombreux les réponses ont été trop
courtes et et même lorsque le peuple
français a voté il n'a pas été tenu du
compte de son souhait nous sommes tous
comptables de cette situation les
rivalités politiciennes nationales
prenant souvent le pas sur le reste le
statut Coo devient souvent le point
d'arrivée des débats européens et
pendant ce temps les voies
eurosceptiques de toute provenance se
sont renforcé en Europe les
nationalismes ont pris confiance le
débat qui s'est déroulé il y a quelques
jours maintenant au Royaume-Uni en a été
le témoignage VI vivant racisme et
xénophobie à tous les étages slogan
réducteur et fausse piste de sortie
inquiète aujourd'hui les Britanniques y
compris ceux qui ont voté pour la sortie
ces crises européennes traduisent
douloureusement une certaine absence de
projet européens et lorsque nous disons
cela lorsque notre groupe dit ça je sais
que ça hérisse le poid à beaucoup
d'entre nous à beaucoup d'entre vous qui
êtes qui sommes des Européens convaincus
mais reconnaissons qu'auudelà des champs
économiques et monétaires au-delà de la
question du marché donc nous avons
échoué à construire une véritable
société européenne David Cameron a
d'ailleurs dit vendredi matin il a
qualifié les Britanniques de nation de
marchand c'est une ironie de l'histoire
que ce soit les marchands qui quittent
les premiers une communauté tournée vers
le marché et ce n'est pas qu'une irronie
c'est aussi le symbole que l'Europe que
nous tous nous navons pas su apporter
plus que ce marché cette faillite doit
être constatée aujourd'hui pour mieux
préparer demain après la sortie du
Royaume-Uni parce que oui le Royaume-Uni
doit quitter l'Europe après ce
référendum après cette séparation après
ce divorce il faut se tourner vers la
famille et la famille c'est l'Europe ce
qui reste cette famille doit rester
soudée unie et affirmer trois principes
le peuple britannique est un peuple ami
et le
restera le Royaume-Uni est un pays ami
et le restera mais quand on divorce on
quitte la maison commune immédiatement
pour habiter peut-être à côté mais en
tout cas pas sous le même toit parce que
sans cela personne ne le comprendrait et
que ça plaise ou pas le peuple a
toujours raison oui le peuple
britannique a voté
le peuple britannique a décidé à
souhaité quitter l'Europe la priorité
doit donc désormais aujourd'hui
d'organiser cette sortie elle ne doit
pas traîner au-delà de ce que prévoit
l'article 50 du traité de de Lisbonne la
sortie britannique est un enjeu de
respect démocratique mais pas seulement
elle est aussi impératif pour sortir
d'une zone d'incertitude qui
pénaliserait les Européens et les
Britanniques ce qui voudrait aujourd'hui
retarder la sortie sont d'ailleurs ceux
qui ont parfois demandé cette sortie il
n'est pas acceptable que les Anglais se
retirent des contraintes mais gardent
les avantages communautaires quand on
quitte l'Europe on a plus de
commissairire européen on a plus de
députés européens on ne touche plus les
aides de la PAC et on est un pays comme
un autre un pays ami mais il faut que
cela soit clair aussi la deuxème
question qui fait suite au brexit quand
il sera effectif et donc celle du projet
européen et s'il a failli il peut
repartir les orateurs précédents l'ont
l'ont évoqué le chef de l'État a
esquissé ce weekend les contours il l'a
fait d'ailleurs depuis plusieurs
semaines mais très clairement ce weekend
et les priorités qu'il a fixé dans les
discussions avec la chancelière avec
l'ensemble des présidents qui vont se
dérouler dans les jours qui viennent
c'est des politique européenne pour la
sécurité et la défense pour
l'investissement dans les nouvelles
technologies pour la jeunesse pour
l'harmonisation fiscale et sociale pour
le renforcement de cette gouvernance
cette trajectoire elle est essentielle
non pas qu'il faillit faacer ce qui
s'est passé jusque- là mais tirer les
conclusions et les conséquences non pas
uniquement du référendum britannique
mais en nous disant clairement
qu'aujourd'hui si on veut que cette
Europe soit mieux comprise alors qu'il
il faut qu'elle soit plus efficace et
plus tourn vers les peuples alors
ensemble nous avons cet objectif C
objectif de bâtir une Europe plus forte
une Europe plus solidaire mais une
Europe qui parallèlement fasse
progresser chacune de nos nations pour
ces orientations nous soutenez nous
soutenons le président de la République
française le gouvernement vous monsieur
le ministre Jean-Marc Kud et donc la
France et tous les discours quels que
soient nos sensibilités politiques qui
abaisseraient qui rabaisserit la France
participerait du dénigrement et
l'affaiblirait dans la discussion
internationale européenne il est temps
oui il est temps que l'Europe retourne
et reparle aux citoyens le projet que
nous devons bâtir maintenant et celui
d'une transformation européenne qui nous
fasse passer de l'Europe du marché à
l'Europe du citoyen un projet qui doit
être celui de l'Europe qui écoute les
citoyens mais il faudra aussi investir
en investissant cet espace démocratique
il sera impératif que l'Europe se
simplifie que l'Europe simplifie son
fonctionnement qu'elle porte des projets
qui est un sens pour les citoyens nos
concitoyens j'en suis persuadé aiment
l'Europe les Français et les Européens
dans leur grande majorité savent ce que
l'Europe leur a apporté en terme de paix
d'ouverture culturelle d'échange et tous
les jeunes qui ont échangé dans les
jumelages après la Seconde Guerre
mondiale savent que cette Europe là est
l'Europe de leur futur et l'Europe de
leur vie ils y vivent à l'intérieur mais
ils ne comprennent plus parfois cette
Europe là qui est au commande et le rôle
des politiques le rôle des gouvernants
et de faire en sorte que leur
prédominance soit là face à la
technocratie et face à la
technostructure européenne le moment est
important 60 ans de construction
européenne ne doivent pas tomber par la
sortie d'un seul membre il y a eu à mon
sens deux événements importants dans
cette construction européenne ça a été
novembre
89 la responsabilité historique d'elmoud
colle un grand Européen qui a compris
que pour que l'Allemagne soit plus forte
elle devait se réunir et pour que
l'Allemagne soit plus forte le peuple
allemand devait se réunir en gomant en
effaçant cette histoire- làà il a rendu
l'Allemagne plus forte ça a coûté cher à
l'Allemagne mais il a eu le courage de
le faire sans démagogie sans populisme
elmou Cole restera comme un grand homme
celui de la réunification et et puis il
restera aussi une autre date une date
beaucoup plus négative c'est celle de
juin 96 et la responsabilité de David
Cameron qui n'a pas eu de vision
prospective pour l'Europe mais qui a eu
une vision politicienne à des fins
d'élections internes il aura réussi à
diviser le peuple britannique et
peut-être à diviser ce royaume à diviser
ce grand pays et il portera peut-être
dans les années qui viennent une lourde
responsabilité de de ce qui se sera
passé dans notre continent alors mes
chers collègues il faut surmonter ce
défi ce défi économique social culturel
politique je suis certain que notre pays
que nous toutes et nous tous malgré nos
divergences malgré nos sensibilités
différentes avons la CAPAC la capacité à
surmonter cette étape en ouvrant un
grand débat sur le projet européen que
nous souhaitons il faut que ce projet
soit clair le ministre des Affaires
étrangère l'a dit tout à l'heure le
débat aura lieu dans les mois qui
viennent pour l'élection présidentielle
et chacun devra apporter ses
orientations en ouvrant un grand débat
sur le projet européen que nous
souhaitons en intégrant les citoyens à
la décision en redonnant du souffle à
l'Europe par un projet porteur d'espoir
il ne s'agit pas d'être négatif il ne
s'agit pas d'être pessimiste il s'agit
d'être réaliste aujourd'hui comme cela
s'est déjà passé l'Europe traverse une
zone de turbulence à nous de faire en
sorte que cette zone de turbulence soit
passée non pas pour nous non pas
uniquement pour nos pays mais pour le
les peuples d'Europe qui doute et si
nous voulons que les peuples d'Europe
comme le peuple de France reprennne
confiance en la politique repr prenne
confiance en ceux qui les gouvernent ça
passera aussi par le respect de la
parole mais ça passera surtout par le
tracée des perspectives pour un grand
marché commun européen celui de la paix
et de la prospérité je vous remercie
merci monsieur le
Président la parole est
maintenant à notre collègue André
gatolin pour 10
minutes vous avez la
parole merci monsieur le président
monsieur le ministre mes chers collègues
jeudi soir après une campagne
excessivement instrumentalisé à des fins
de politique intérieure 52 % des
Britanniques ont pris la lourde décision
de quitter l'Union européenne c'est un
choix démocratique que nous respectons
et qui doit aujourd'hui être mise en
œuvre à travers une activation rapide de
l'article 50 du TUE car après ce cout
sans précédent porter à une union
européenne déjà bien mal en point il ne
faudrait pas que de longues et
tortueuses négociations sur les modalité
de sortie viennent accaparer nos
diplomaties respectives et paralyser les
institutions européennes pendant au
moins 2 ans ce précisément à un moment
où il est désormais urgent et je dirais
même vital d'engager un véritable débat
de fond sur l'indispensable renouveau du
projet européen l'heure est donc grave
pas seulement pour les Britanniques mais
pour l'ensemble de l'Union et de ses
citoyens cependant s'il y a au moins un
aspect salutaire dans cette affaire
c'est que tous nos responsables
politiques nationaux parlent enfin de
l'Europe et que un moins à un an et
moins de l'élection présidentielle cette
question figure désormais en haut de
leur agenda politique face à cette crise
inédite il est plus que jamais urgent de
nous interroger
sur notre responsabilité collective en
tant qu'étatmembre dans cette lente mais
constante dérive de l'idée
européenne nous avons effectivement
dessiné je crois les prémisses possibles
d'un rejet citoyen du projet européen
lorsque nous sommes en rien orientés
tête baissée et presque exclusivement
vers un grand marché unique et vers une
austérité accrue qui a surtout accentué
les inégalités sociales en Europe nous
les avons aussi dessiné lorsque nous
n'avons pas eu le courage de doter
l'Union d'un budget suffisamment
ambitieux alors que nous demandons sans
cesse et chaque jour à l'Europe de
prendre en charge de nouvelles missions
ces ressources sont limitées à 1 % du
produit intérieur brut de l'Union et
désormais presque exclusivement alimenté
par des contributions nationales qui
font l'objet d'un marchandage toujours
plus âpre quant au retour attendu par
chaque État membre de surcroix
l'abaissement continue qui s'est produit
des droits de douane à l'entrée de
l'Union au cours des 20 dernières années
a drastiquement diminué nos ressources
propres alors Monsieur le Ministre
comment construire une Europe solidaire
qui protège et qui investit avec aussi
peu de moyens pour agir car en général
c'est lorsqu'une crise surgit et que
nous ne parvenons pas à la résoudre à
l'échelle national que nous nous nous
nous tournons soudainement et en urgence
vers l'Europe mais comme c'est le cas
dans le dans le cas récent de la crise
des réfugiés à défaut de prévention et
de solidarité la réponse qui est à l'ORD
donné est chaotique et désordonnée or le
sens fondamental du projet européen
c'est précisément de se projeter
d'anticiper ensemble les défis à
affronter si cette responsabilité
collective de l'Europe est indégnable
elle ne doit pas faire oublier la
responsabilité aussi de notre pays la
France membrre fondateur de l'Union et
seconde puissance européenne à ce titre
quelle proposition forte avons-nous
porté auprès de nos collègues européens
au cours des 10 dernières années et plus
prquement monsieur le ministre que
reste-t-il désormais de notre influence
réelle au sein des institutions
européennes nous avons laissé et ça ne
date pas d'hier ça date d'au moins 10-
15 ans laisser se déliter la relation
franco-allemande qui a longtemps
constitué
le moteur de l'Union la réalité
aujourd'hui à un moment où nous devrions
agir de concert pour un véritable
sursaut de l'Europe c'est que nous avons
bien du mal à nous entendre et à nous
comprendre un peu à l'instar de nos amis
britannique nous Français nous drapons
volontiers dans la grandeur de notre
passé national sans reconnaître
aujourd'hui notre profonde dépendance
aux autres France 5e puissance mondiale
c'est par cette ritournelle usoir que
presque tous les prétendants à
l'élection présidentielle a guuisent
l'imaginaire politique des électeurs
sans oser dire que nous ne devons notre
maintien à se r fragile dans la
hiérarchie mondiale que grâce à notre
appartenance et à l'Union et ce ce
qu'elle nous a apporté au cours des
dernières décennies retournel illusoire
aussi parce que la réalité qui s'annonce
et que nous cachons très pudiquement à
nos concitoyens c'est que à l'horizon de
2005 au plus tard plus aucun pays
européen pas même l'Allemagne ne
figurera parmi les 20 premières
puissances de la planète alors de la
montée en puissance de pays qui n'ont
plus d'émergents que le nom comment
pouvons-nous penser l'avenir de notre
pays sans penser l'échelle européenne la
seule susceptible d'imposer une
véritable régulation dans un processus
de mondialisation effrainé les
fondements actuels de la crise de
l'Union ne sont pas pas le seul fait du
brexit qui n'en est aujourd'hui en fait
que le révélateur ces fondements
remontent en réalité à une vingtaine
d'années lorsqu'à défaut de nous doter
d'une vision politique commune appuyé
sur une véritable gouvernance
démocratique nous avons choisi de nous
limité à la construction d'un grand
marché unique que nous avons largement
délégué à une commission européenne
emprunte en la matière d'un dogmatisme
néolibéral totalement suranné celle-ci
s'est en effet érigée négociatrice
exclusive d'une multitude de traités
bilatéraux et à défaut de favoriser
l'émergence d'une vigoureuse politique
industrielle européenne elle préfère
plutôt développer une insensée politique
de la concurrence y compris dans les
secteurs les plus stratégiques pour
notre économie car avec les règles qui
on cours aujourd'hui la création
d'Airbus heureusement bien antérieur
n'aurait sans doute jamais pu voir le le
le jour ce sont ces mêmes règles qui
aujour' aujourd'hui entrave l'émergence
d'une véritable industrie européenne du
numérique et d'un grand plan
d'investissement en faveur de la nécion
nécessaire transition énergétique de nos
économies car il faut bien le dire dans
ces deux domaines et dans bien d'autres
nos concurents nord-américains et
asiatiques sont loin d'avoir la même
retenue en recourant parfois de manière
massive à l'aide publique pour stimuler
leur économie alors conscient que cette
politique est devenue hors sol le
vischancelier monsieur Sigmar Gabriel et
le président du Parlement européen
Monsieur Martin Schulz ont proposé
vendredi dernier de transformer la
Commission européenne en un véritable
gouvernement et surtout de le placer sur
le contrôle démocratique de deux
chambres à savoir le Parlement européen
et une assemblée qui représenterait les
États-membres monsieur le ministre
comment le gouvernement français
accueille-t-il cette proposition par
ailleurs et contenu des grillfs
croissants des citoyens européens à
l'encore des à l'encontre des accords
commerciaux bilatéraux dont les
négociations restent conduites dans une
très grande opacité par la Commission ne
pensez-vous pas urgent de réclamer
immédiatement un moratoire sur ces
traités en cours et en prévision le
temps au moins d'en repenser les
finalités et les
modalités au-delà de ces questions de
nature économique la relance et la
cohérence du projet européen doit
parallèlement passer par d'autres
initiatives à rendre l'Union plus
solidaire et plus proche des
préoccupations des citoyens il faut bien
évidemment avancer à marche forcé vers
une harmonisation des règles fiscales et
sociales au sein de l'Union afin que
certains États-membres cessent de capter
indûent une bonne partie de la richesse
produite sur le territoire de l'Union
car il faut bien dire il est pour le
moins paradoxal de constater aujourd'hui
qu'une partie des pays jugés parmi les
plus vertueux en matière de respect des
critères de convergence budgétaire ça
donne à des pratiques fiscales qui n'ont
rien de respectable au regard de
l'intérêt général européen donc propose
également un renforcement significatif
de la politique de sécurité et de
défense commune pour faire face aux
crises externes et internes que nous
affrontons pourquoi pas mais cette
question appelle de nombreux débat
notamment celui de ne pas s'ver dans une
politique répressive sans respect de nos
principes d'accueil et et surtout sans
la mise en œuvre en amont d'une
véritable politique d'aide au
développement et de prévention des
conflits dans les zones à risque mais le
problème majeur de toutes ces belles
propositions et qui fleurissent
aujourd'hui et depuis quelques jours
c'est qu'elles suppose pour pouvoir
entrer en action de passer outre la
fameuse règle de l'unanimité des
États-membres qui aujourd'hui à 27 comme
hier à 28 constitue un véritable verrou
qui bloque toute possibilité de
changement la grande difficulté de
l'Union européenne c'est que l'essentiel
de ces institutions et de ses modes de
fonctionnement a été conçu à une époque
de prospérité pour 6 ou 10 états et à
une époque où la mondialisation et la
conjonction des crises n'avaient pas la
même intensité qu'aujourd'hui alors le
saut en avant de l'Europe est inévitable
et si nous ne voulons pas PIR dans le
processus de composition qui s'est
amorcé il faut agir vite et fort mais ce
saut ne pourra se pérer qu'avec
l'agrément de nos concitoyens quit à
devoir entériner au passage le principe
d'une Europe à plusieurs vitesses mais
cela n'aurait aucun sens aujourd'hui je
crois de soumettre la question
européenne à référendum sans qu'un tel
projet renouvelé n'ait été sérieusement
discuté et élaboré au préalable nous
l'idée de lancer un processus
constituant tel qu'il a été proposé par
les écologistes me paraît être le bon
nous espérons monsieur le ministre que
le gouvernement de la France sera en la
matière prendre toutes ses
responsabilités je vous remercie merci
mon cher
collègue la parole est à notre
collègue Philippe
adenud pour
le rassemblement des sénateurs de
figurant sur la liste d'aucun groupe
et pour 3
minutes vous avez la parole
président merci monsieur le président
monsieur le ministre des Affaires
étrangères mesdames messieurs les
ministres chers collègues le Royaume-Uni
va peut-être demander à sortir de
l'Europe dans la foulée du référendum je
dis peut-être parce que hier soir
j'étais avec un chef d'entreprise
irlandais qui me racontait qu'ils
étaient obligés d'impocher beaucoup de
monde pour faire en sorte que les
doubles les doubles passeports puissent
éventuellement se préparer à
d'éventuelles difficultés et nous ne
savons pas encore ce que va faire
l'Écosse et donc je dis peut-être je
pense que dans le contexte actuel il
serait utile que nous empruntions à nos
voisins d'outr manche leur flegm si pour
une fois nous arrêtions de donner à
penser que tout est noir ou blanc
vouloir faire croire à chaque fois qu'il
y a une consultation de ce type que ce
sera ou bien catastrophique ou bien
merveilleux est une posture qui sera
systématiquement démenti par les faits
l'Union européenne ne peut pas tout
n'est pas responsable de tout et il
existe des pays qui ne sont pas dans
l'Union ils ne sont pas en faillite et
nous commerçons avec eux leur monnaie
n'est pas nécessairement dévaluée aussi
je pense qu'il serait utile que nous
examinions la situation avec sans froid
dans une approche pragmatique ce sera
d'ailleurs peut-être pour nous
l'occasion de vérifier si le Royaume-Uni
euh recevait plus que ce qu'il
donnait cela devrait surtout nous
conduire à réfléchir sur ce qui entraîne
progressivement les pays européens à
rejeté l'Europe d'aujourd'hui celle qui
est tatillonne qui veut s'occuper de
tout de la fessée comme du contenu des
cantines qui est une machine à produire
des normes des contraintes
administratives et qui dans les faits
peuvent même générer entre les
entreprises des États-membres une
concurrence déloyale liée à des
divergences de transposition
d'interprétation et cetera et si nous
profis de cette période pour redéfinir
ce qui nous paraît essentiel nous avons
la monnaie unique c'est très clairement
un progrès et un avantage nous devions
avoir une défense commune où est-elle
nous l'harmonisation fiscale devait
aller de paire avec l'euro où en est-on
où sont enfin les règles sociales
harmonisées on ne les voit guerre dans
l'espace inter intracommunautaire de
dumping social sur le marché du travail
moins d'Europe mieux d'Europe voilà ce
qui devrait mobiliser nos forces
redéfinir ce que nous devons mettre en
commun est une urgence et ce n'est pas
la fuite en avant qui va faire aimer
l'Europe au peuples finalement nous
verrons bien si les Britanniques vont
matérialiser juridiquement leur
intention de sortir dans ce cas il
existe des règles appliquons-les mais
j'attire votre attention sur la
nécessité de saisir l'occasion pour
remettre à plat un certain nombre de
dérives sinon je crains que l'hémorragie
se poursuivent au fait les Britanniques
sortant le français redeviendra-t-il la
langue officielle de travail la Banque
centrale européenne qui fonctionne pour
sa part uniquement en anglais depuis sa
création va-t-elle pouvoir continuer à
utiliser la langue d'un pays hors Union
je souhaitais par ce trait qui pourrait
relever de l'humour britannique
mettre en relief ce qu'il peut y avoir
d'absurde dans notre façon d'organiser
nos institutions en cultivant l'espoir
que ce brexit réveille les consciences
merci beaucoup mon cher
collègue la parole est maintenant au
président Jacques mzard pour le groupe
du Rassemblement démocratique social et
européen vous avez la parole monsieur
président merci monsieur le président
monsieur le ministre des Affaires
étrangères messieurs les mesdames
messieurs les ministres mes chers
collègues Albon une fois encore a choisi
le grand
large comme au temps où le soleil ne se
couchait jamais sur son empire en se
tournant vers l'océan elle a sans doute
déclenché une tempête tant sur ses côtes
que sur cell du continent mais la
tempête heureusement se calme toujours
en premier
lieu respectons le vote des
anglais c'est un peuple qui n'a pas de
leçon de démocratie à recevoir
disonsleur bon
vent nos décisions consécutive à ce
brexit doivent être fermes conformes aux
intérêts de notre nation et de la
sauvegarde de l'Europe mais non
vexatoire à l'égard d'un peuple ami dont
nous n'oublions pas que voici ant des
centaines de milliers de jeunes soldats
tombés sur la somme pour la liberté
cette liberté quiass su si
magnifiquement écarné 25 ans après
Winston
Churchill loin de sombrer dans le
catastrophisme faisons une analyse des
raisons de ce choc qui ont amené un
grand pays démocratique à mettre en jeu
son unité territoriale son développement
économique pour se réconforter avec
lui-même ou se recroqueviller sur
lui-même cette analyse faite et nous y
reviendrons n'hésitons pas à rechercher
les aspects éventuellement positif de
cette rupture attaché à la construction
européenne notre groupe l' viscéralement
comment oublierions-nous que Maurice
fort a signé au nom de la France le
traité de
Rome considérons tout d'abord que cet
électrochoc a un côté positif en ce
qu'il met l'Union européenne au pied du
mur où elle modifie drastiquement son
fonctionnement où elle sombrera ne
donnons pas aux Anglais en plus la
satisfaction d'avoir à dire nous avons
eu la sagesse de quitter le navire avant
son
naufrage la sortie de l'Angleterre va
modifier le centre de gravité européen
au niveau géopolitique moins
d'atlantisme moins de culte de la
concurrence la situation mes chers
collègues imposent des mesures rapides
en premier lieu par rapport à
l'Angleterre elle ne saurait imposer son
calendrier et jouer la
montre l'Angleterre est entrée à reculon
dans l'Europe elle doit en sortir avec
fairplay l'Angleterre ne peut avoir le
beurre l'argent du beurre et le sourire
de la
crémière l'article 50 doit être appliqué
avec comme objectif de conclure dans les
2 ans et dans ce lapse de temps il
paraît opportun de régler la question
des Rabet sur Rabet défavorables la
France mais aussi mes chers collègues de
ramener la langue anglaise à son nouveau
poids dans l'Europe celui de l'Irlande
et de
Malte une évidence les concessions
faites à l'Angleterre pour qu'elle
adhère et qu'elle reste ont été inutille
voire
néfaste cependant ne jetons pas la
pierre aux Anglais c'est une
responsabilité collective et rien ne dit
qu'un référendum en France n'aurait pas
la même
issue mes chers chers collègues l'Union
européenne s'est coupé des citoyens
européens par l'absence de
responsabilité politique
suffisante la belle idée européenne pour
construire une paix durable et le
développement économique a été dévasté
par ce qui est chaque jour vécu comme un
pouvoir technocratique non démocratique
une machine à fabriquer des directives
le temple de la concurrence et de la
finance à la sauce
anglo-saxone une technostructure faisant
du Conseil européen le secrétariat
général de la commission ce qui est
quand même un comble la nature à horreur
du vide encore plus en politique ni et
l'immense déficit démocratique serait IR
responsable les rejets populaires du
traité constitutionnel de 2005 le nom
irlandais au traité de Lisbonne était
des alertes rouges mais le déni s'est
poursuivi et nous le payons tous
aujourd'hui nous avons laissé se mettre
en place une Europe trop technocratique
occupé à réglementer la taille des cages
à
palmipetgas mais incapable de régler la
dette autrement que par
l'austérité ou encore incapable de
s'entendre rapidement sur les moyens de
gérer les migrants nous avons laissé
s'installer une Europe qui se passe de
la vie des parlements nationaux sur des
dossiers aussi fondamentaux par exemple
que celui de la négociation du traité
transatlantique avant de donner des
leçons aux autres commençons par balayer
devant notre porte et si j'ose dire en
procédure
accélérée ce n'est pas un message
subliminal l'élection des députés
européens en France est une palinodie
des circonscriptions artificielles une
machine à recycler les surplus des
partis dominant et une
tribune et une tribune pour les
uropé des députés qui malgré quelques
heureuses exceptions sont déconnectés
des citoyens seconde urgence notre
Parlement avec le concours du
gouvernement doit donner toute sa place
aux Affaires européennes avec une vraie
information systématique des
parlementaires et de vrais débats
préalabl au conseils
européens troisème mesure simple
messieurs les ministres mesdames
messieurs les ministres que le
gouvernement par le canal des PR leure
fasse passer chaque mois dans toutes les
mairies une information systématique
synthétique pratique sur les dossiers
européens avec des interlocuteurs dédiés
dans chaque département je pourrais
décliner nombre d'autres propositions
mais j'insisterai sur l'impérieuse
nécessité de rendre pour nos
collectivités nos agriculteurs nos
entreprises les procédures de dossierers
européens pratica pour tous ceux qui ont
recours c'est l'usine à gaz le comble de
la bureaucratie aggravé par la are qui
est un modèle en la
matière il est plus que temps de donner
la main au Parlement que des commissions
spéciales soit créé en lien avec le
gouvernement pour mettre à plat tous ces
problèmes et tenter de les résoudre vite
sur la question européenne c'est en
concertation avec le Parlement que
l'exécutif doit élaborer une politique
car l'Europe se
reformera se réformera ou se disloquera
et disons-le la campagne prés enti ne va
pas faciliter les choses pour résoudre
l'équation oui à l'expression du peuple
mais non au
populisme notre commission des finances
et son rapporteur Alber de monelfier ont
rédigé un excellent rapport sur les
conséquences du brexit les impacts
financiers économiques sont réels mais
ne justifi pas une dramatisation
excessive le risque le débat sont
d'abord politiques sur les institutions
européennes comment supporter le carcan
d'une commission hyper technocratique
qui ne devrait être que le secrétariat
général du Conseil des ministres premier
enjeu redonner le pouvoir aux
représentants du
peuple débat sur la nécessité de
recentrer les directives européennes sur
les grands sujets et de ne plus accabler
nos territoires de directive sur la
couleur des oranges les remorques des
tracteurs et j'enass et des pires débat
sur le nécessaire recentrage de l'action
européenne sur un noyau dur
mais plus large que les six pays
fondateurs une Europe à vitesse variable
ça existe déjà nous l'avons avec
l'euro donc c'est possible débat sur la
logique qui exe pour les pays de l'euro
de rechercher une harmonisation fiscale
et sociale sinon on voit bien que nous
courons encore à des difficultés
dramatiques débat sur la définition
d'une stratégie économique on a laissé
la porte ouverte à T
au marché sans même protéger la
frontière européenne tout en appliquant
à nos entreprises des contraintes
administratifes
absurdes débat sur une plus grande
solidarité du noyau dur en matière
d'immigration et de défense la France
peut-elle et doit-elle continuer à
assumer quasiment seul les missions
extérieures pour avancer sur tout cela
il faut une vraie une vraie volonté
politique dénué de visions
électoralistes une volonté d'homme
état sous la 4e République après l'échec
de la CED nos gouvernements ont provoqué
la conférence de Messine au cours de
laquelle les épures du traité de r du
Rome furent posé oui il faut une
nouvelle conférence de Messine avec des
propositions fortes mes chers collègues
à l'air des grands empires qui se
constituent ou se reconstituent de la
Chine aux USA en passant par l'Inde la
Russie et d'autres le choix ne peut être
au lâche délitement de l'Europe qui
entraînera aussi inexorablement le
délitement des nations autour de
régionalistes
indépendantist c'est avec les nations
qui fédérent chacun de nos peuples et
les rassurent que doit poursuivre et
réussir l'Europe que nous voulons celle
d'un espace de liberté d'expression et
de pensée de création de liberté de
circuler d'entreprendre sans dictate ni
de la finance ni de la bureaucratie
l'Europe ne doit pas être celle de la
souffrance sociale mais celle de la
recherche de l'innovation des grands
travaux cela c'est une belle aventure
c'est le beau projet pour les
générations qui viennent y renoncer
serait indigne de notre histoire tout
cela il nous faut à tous de la volonté
et de la confiance dans notre
peuple merci monsieur le
président
la parole est maintenant au président
François
zoquetto pour le groupe udi Union
centriste vous avez la parole monsieur
le
Président merci monsieur le Président
Monsieur le Ministre mesdames et
messieurs les ministres mes chers
collègues le peuple britannique a décidé
de quitter l'Union européenne 43 ans
après l'avoir rejointe c'est évidemment
un choix crucial pour le Royaume-Uni
mais qui aura des conséquences lourdes
pour ces 27 partenaires et puisque les
peuples nous en joignent à parler
d'Europe sans langue de bois disons-le
clairement c'est un choc ce fut un choc
vendredi matin alors bien sûr nous
pourrions nous rassurer en constatant
que le Royaume Uni c'est toujours perçu
à part que son histoire sa géographie
justifie un traitement dérogatoire un
quasi droit de véau sur les aspirations
majoritair de ses partenaires nous
pourrions également nous demander si ces
accommandements successif n'ont pas
engendré chez les Britanniques le
sentiment qu'il seraiit dans leur droit
de sortir de l'Europe le jour où ils
estimeraiit qu'il n'en tirerait plus
suffisamment d'avantage porté ainsi par
une logique
utilitariste sans idéal mais l'URE n'est
pas au regret elle est au
sursaut l'histoire peut nous inciter à
l'optimisme mes chers collègu car depuis
70 ans l'Europe avance en surmontant des
crises
successive et nous pouvons faire du vote
de jeudi dernier un
électrochoc dont nous nous dirons dans
10 ans qu'il a servi à quelque
chose là est notre responsabilité celle
des États-membres et de la France en
particulier d'abord pour mettre en œuvre
la sortie du Royaume-Uni de l'Union
européenne et ensuite pour relancer je
dirais plutôt en parallèle pour relancer
la construction
européenne la sortie elle doit être R
sans ambigué elle doit être menée sans
ressentiment sans
complaisance sans ressentiment car les
électeurs britanque ont exprimé ce que
beaucoup de citoyens européens
pensent nos concitoyens s'interrogent
sur l'utilité de l'Union européenne ils
considèrent souvent qu'elle est la cause
de nombre de leurs difficultés et encore
plus souvent qu'elle ne sert à rien nous
devons être sans ressentiment également
car les dirigeants britanniques ne sont
pas les seuls ils ne sont pas les
premiers à avoir instrumentalisé
l'Europe pour des calculs parfois
médiocres souvenons-nous de 2005 ne
négligeons pas notre capacité à
incriminer l'Europe au quotidien en lieu
et place de nos faiblesses de nos
lâchetés répéter sans ressentiment aussi
car n'oublions pas notre collègue Joé
Cox lâchement assassiné il y a quelques
jours
seulement sans ressentiment mais sans
complaisance
car les Britanniques ont fait un choix
éclairé après avoir été
informés ils doivent assumer ce choix
sans entraîner les 450 millions
d'habitants des 27 autres pays dans la
spirale de la
dislocation ça signifie deux choses
d'abord les négociations de sortie
doivent s'engager sans délai dès ce mois
de juillet car ce n'est pas cela a déjà
été dit ce n'est pas à celui qui a
décidé unilatéralement de partir de
dicter également son
agenda les Britanniques doivent désigné
c'est euh leur question doivent désigner
un Premier ministre qui sera en
légitimité de conduire ces négociations
les négociations doivent être rapides 2
ans paraît un délai
maximum tout cela signifie également
qu'il ne peut pas y avoir d'ambigué sur
l'issue des négociations l'objectif
n'est plus de ménager la chèvre et le
chou d'espérer trouver un compromis qui
permettrait aux Britanniques de
conserver l'essentiel des avantages d'un
pays membre tout en échappant aux
obligations et aux contraintes d'une
démarche
collective nous pérons tous un prix à ne
plus être que 27 les Britanniques et
nous-même ça nous empêchera pas d'être
intelligent de trouver des formules
coniliables à nos intérêts respectifs et
disons-le ce sont les intérêts de
l'Union Européenne à 27 qui doivent être
défendus sans état d'âme dans cette
négociation je le dis car si nous
n'avons pas cette franchise si nous ne
sommes pas guidés par cette règle si
nous ne sommes pas clairs et fermes
nous courons le risque d'un délitement
de l'Union européenne tous les
populistes vont s'engouffrer dans la
brèche en affirmant à des opinions abusé
que les dommages finalement d'une sortie
de l'Europe sont minimes et que après
tout on pourra essayer il nous faut tuer
l'œuf il nous faut tuer dans l'œuf cette
perspective qui n'est pas seulement
théorique et qui s'approche dans de
nombreux
pays suite au brexit aucun doute ne doit
être possible la sortie du Royaume-Uni
ne peut pas être un
précédent suivi d'autres situations
comparables la construction européenne
pour nous centriste n'est pas réversible
et l'Union n'est pas un aimable club
dans lequel on pourrait rentrer puis
sortir à sa guise l'Union européenne est
un processus qui est destiné à aller
plus loin
là et quand elle est utile au
peuple monsieur le ministre face à
l'immensité de la tâche je vous propose
d'associer les parlementaires français
qu'ils soient nationaux ou européens à
vos travaux et nous pensons qu'il serait
pertinent de créer très vite un comité
de suivi
transpartisan avec lequel le
gouvernement pourra dialoguer plus vous
serez
transparent plus vous serez à l'écoute
plus nous pourrons soutenir la position
française
la relance la relance de l'idéal
européen doit être menée
simultanément je parlerai même plutôt
que de relance de
renaissance car l'Europe se trouve dans
une situation critique
elle est désormais privée de soutien
populaire elle ne sait plus démontrer
que nos situation individuelle serait
bien plus fragile sans
elle nous devons donc réviser les
principes de notre
association la famille politique que je
représente ici a la chance d'être unie
sur la question de la construction
européenne nous avons la conviction que
les citoyens seront mieux protégés dans
l'Union européenne à condition que
celle-ci soit plus forte plus intégrée
et surtout plus tourné vers ses
habitants bien sûr et malheureusement
l'option d'une sortie de crise par le
haut c'est-à-dire vers plus de
fédéralisme n'est aujourd'hui pas
audible
par nos concitoyens tant la défiance
envers le projet européen s'est installé
en conséquence nous devons passer par
une étape
intermédiaire qui consiste à recréer ce
que j'appellerais une envie d'Europe qui
n'existe plus aujourd'hui chez bon
nombre de nos
concitoyens la politique le politique
doit à nouveau primer dans le processus
de décision européen il doit supplanter
la technostructure mais qui n'est que le
reflet de nous-même quand bien même
cette technostructure est la mieux
intentionnée pour cela nous devons
changer la gouvernance de l'Europe les
députés que nous envoyons à Strasbourg
doivent être les meilleurs
oui nos ministres doivent être à
Bruxelles lorsque les décisions qui
impactent la vie des gens se
prennent sur le plan des symboles qui
crispe nous ne pouvons pas continuer à
laisser la commission imposer la rigueur
à tous sauf à elle-même
il nous faut surtout revenir aux
fondamentaux de l'équilibre entre
l'Union européenne et les États-membres
la subsidiarité dont on parle temps doit
être redéfinie et elle doit enfin
prévaloir au stade auquel nous en sommes
l'Europe doit se mobiliser sur quelques
enjeux
essentiels la
sécurité intérieur et extérieur la
politique
migratoire l'harmonisation des
politiques fiscal sociale et
environnemental l'identification de
projets industriels cruciaux qui
prévaleent sur le dogme du libre échange
absolu et sur la priorité qui a été trop
donné au monde de la finance et le
départ des Britanniques constitue à cet
égard une réelle opportunité pour nous
pour le reste laissons vivre nos
spécificité laissons prospérer les
initiatives sans immédiatement les
traduire en me comme nous faisons depuis
trop
longtemps l'Europe doit incarner des
relations fortes utiles au citoyens qui
parle à nos concitoyens je vous
remercie merci monsieur le
Président la parole est à notre collègue
Pierre Laurent pour le groupe communiste
républicain et
citoyens
vous avez la
parole monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Ministre des Affaires étrangères
messieurs les ministres mesdames et
messieurs les ministres mes chers
collègues avec le résultat du référendum
britannique qui a donné la victoire aux
partisans du brexit un grand peuple
européen vient de décider de quitter
l'Union européenne c'est un terrible
échec pour l'Union
européenne ce résultat intervient au
terme d'une année de surenchè libéral et
xénophobe orchestré par les classes
dirigeantes de la droite britannique qui
ont voulu ce référendum de David Cameron
à Nadel Farage en passant par Boris
Johnson mais surtout ce résultat signe à
la faillite du projet libéral et
austéritaire européen entièrement tourné
vers la mise en
concurrence ce projet que la plupart
d'entre vous ont soutenu parce que que
vous aviez raison monsieur rafarin les
responsabilités sont ici ce projet que
vous avez tous largement soutenu divise
et conduit à la dislocation il est
incapable d'unir les peuples européens
vers un destin commun fait de paix de
justice et de progrès social partagé ce
vote est un des aveux singlants pour
pour tous ceux qui depuis des années ont
poussé les feux d'une construction
libérale de l'Union européenne sans
jamais écouter les alertes successives
venu des peuples européens a commencé
par Le Nôtre la dernière décennie est
jalonnée de dénis démocratique le sort
réservé au référendum de 2005 quiici
nombre d'entre vous ont méprisé
ou au vote des Grecs en
2015 d'ailleurs les Grecs ne demandaient
pas seulement à rester dans l'Europe ils
demandaient à échapper à des politiques
d'austérité qui leur sont toujours
aujourd'hui imposé et bien
ces dénis démocratiques successifs voilà
le
résultat la première leçon est donc
claire respecter les les peuples leur
vote et la seule méthode pour construire
une union de solidarité dont chacun
voudra rester pour coopérer il est grand
temps de l'entendre si nous ne voulons
pas voir l'Europe continuer à sombrer
dans le fracas des guerres économiques
où les morts s'appellent chômeurs
précaires et migrants le projet
ééritaire européens imposé au peuple
depuis le traité de Lisbonne et la crise
du capitalisme financier de 2008 doit
être stoppé le temps est venu oui le
temps est venu d'une refondation
progressiste de de l'Europe tourner vers
le progrès social et il faut d'urgence
mettre le cap vers la sortie de
l'austérité toute tentation de
tergiverser avec cette exigence devient
aujourd'hui pure folie elle laissera une
place grandissante à toutes les dérives
RAC xénophobe qui défigurent déjà
largement l'Europe elle laissera la
place à toutes les rivalités
nationalistes et leur cortège de conflit
de tension et de guerre les premières
déclarations entendues il faut le dire
ne nous rassure pas les dirigeants
européens vont-ils chercher une nouvelle
fois à fuir leur responsabilité et à
faire payer au peuple du Royaume-Uni la
faillite de leurs dirigeants pour
ensuite continuer comme avant nous vous
le disons il faut arrêter de jouer avec
leu feu le choix souverain du peuple
britannique doit être respecté sans
chantage sans menace de représaill et
les négociation du brexit mené avec
responsabilité d'autant que
manifestement soit dit entre nous
personne pas plus les dirigeants
britanniques qui ont poussé à cela que
les autres ne semblent réellement
préparés et il ne suffira pas d'invoquer
l'article 50 pour régler tous les
problèmes ce n'est pas la finance c'est
cela dont nous nrions déb qui doit être
une nouvelle fois protégé comme en 2008
mais tous ceux qui font les richesses
des nations les travailleurs les
citoyens et les migrants le Royaume-Uni
est un de nos grands voisins anglais
Gallois écossais tous doivent être
écoutés comme doivent l'être les
irlandais dont l'avenir commun est à
nouveau interpellé par cette situation
inédite nous vous proposons qu'une
commission spéciale parlementaire
commune aux deux assemblées en présence
de tous les groupes soit créé sur le
suivi du brexit afin que toutes les
décisions prises le soi en toute
transparence et sous contrôle du
Parlement pour tout ce qui engagera la
France mais je l'ai dit mais je l'ai dit
l'essentiel c'est l'engagement déterminé
de la France dans la bataille de la
refondation progressiste de l'Europe le
temps est venu d'avancer vers une
nouvelle union refondée union de peuples
et de nations libres souverain et
associé tourné vers le humain la justice
sociale débarrasser de l'emprise
prédatriste de la finance cette nouvelle
union solidaire et coopérative
impliquera par étape des nouveaux
traités ils doivent être construits sous
le contrôle des peuples européens avec
de nouvelles procédures démocratiques en
respectant la souveraineté de tous
l'Europe autoritaire c'est fini il
serait temps de le comprendre la France
doit être à l'initiative d'un immense
débat public national et européen d'une
ampleur inédite et nous faisons deux
propositions qu'à l'échelle européenne
la France propose le lancement d'états
généraux de la refondation progressiste
européenne en commençant par mobiliser
les gouvernements les forces politiques
sociales et citoyennes disponibles elles
sont nombreuses Paris pourrait être
rapidement le lieu d'une première grande
conférence citoyenne
européenne en France nous proposons de
mettre en place une instance inédite une
conférence citoyenne permanente chargé
de construire ce nouveau projet européen
et le mandat de la France en Europe oui
oui ça va vous changer ça va vous
changer elle pourrait
associer cette conférence
citoyenne des représentants de toutes
les forces politiques des parlementaires
et des élus locaux de tout niveau et de
toute
sensibilité tous les syndicats les ONG
et le monde
associatif toutes les décisions qui
engagent la France au plan européen
doivent être désormais soumises au
Parlement et associé cette conférence
citoyenne les propositions pour un
nouveau traité pourrai être soumises à
référendum le moment
venu sans attendre des décisions doivent
être prises pour stopper le train fou de
l'Europe libérale et du dumping social
cette Europe des traités autoritaire et
imposé qui jette les peuples et les
travailleurs les contre les autres en
Europe nous faisons des propositions
précises trois immédiates contre le
dumping social la France ne doit pas
ratifier les traités de libre échange
tafta CTA et tisa elle doit exiger la
reconnaissance du caractère mixte de ces
accords donc l'obligation d'un vote
conjoint au Parlement européen et dans
chaque parlement national cela vaut tout
de suite pour le CTA puisque je le
rappelle la commission EUR envisage
début juillet la non reconnaissance du
caractère mixte de ce traité aucune
signature de la France ne doit être
engagé sans le Parlement et nous
attendons sur ce point des réponses
précises la France doit suspendre
l'adoption et la mise en œuvre dans
notre législation des recommandations
européennes de déréglementation sociale
à commencé par la loi travail à la
droite et au
gouvernement JEE la question
après avoir versé cet après-midi des
larmes de crocodil sur le brexit
allez-vous adopter tout de suite
après vous la droite au
Sénat et vous et vous le gouvernement à
l'Assemblée nationale grâce au dénis
démocratique du
493 cette loi cette loi qui va
contribuer à généraliser le dumping
social aux uns et aux autres aux uns et
aux autres après ce qui vient de se
passer dimanche dernier je le dis c'est
socialement
irresponsable et politiquement ce serait
un nouvel acte de mépris à l'égard de
notre peuple ici comme au Royaume-Uni la
fracture n'est pas seulement sociale
elle est politique et
démocratique enfin la France doit
renforcer son engagement pour exiger une
renégociation immédiate de la directive
sur le travail détaché et adopter ici en
France les mesure pour stopper son usage
scandaleux contre le droit du
travail nous vous proposons aussi des
décisions fortes pour sortir de
l'austérité puisque nous allons entrer
dans la discussion
budgétaire la France doit demander la
renégociation immédiate du traité
budgétaire et déclarer qu'elle ne veut
plus encadrer son soutien au servicees
public à l'investissement public et au
collectivité locale par les critères
idiots et contreproductifs du pacte de
stabilité
pour financer ces dépenses la France
doit proposer la création d'un fond
européen alimenté par les 80 milliards
d'euros qui qu'injecte chaque mois la
Banque centrale européenne à fonds
perdus pour l'emploi dans les marchés
financiers l'argent doit aller à
l'emploi et non plus aux banques et aux
dividendes enfin la France doit agir
sans tarder pour une conférence
européenne sur la dette qui continue
d'être ler tous les budgets de nos
nations et un plan de lutte drastique
contre l'évasion fiscale et le dumping
fiscal voilà mes chers collègues ce que
nous proposons en un mot et un seul face
à la faillite de votre projet européen
assez de mots des
actes
merci la parole est au président Bruno
rill
et pour 10
minutes monsieur le Président Monsieur
le Ministre des Affaires étrangères
mesdames messieurs les ministres
Messieurs les Présidents cher
Jean-Pierre affarin cher Jean biset les
Anglais ont dit non et le brexit est
d'abord une double amputation une
amputation bien sûr pour l'Europe parce
que le Royaume-Uni est une grande nation
celle de la Bagna carta celle du
parlementarisme celle qui a mêlé son
sang à plusieurs reprises au siècle
dernier au sang de notre
nation un pays qui sans doute est le
seul avec la France à avoir un regard
global stratégique sur le monde entier
un pays qui a une armée qui a une
volonté de défense c'est donc une
imputation pour l'Europe toute entière C
aussi sans doute et peut-être une
amputation aussi pour nos amis anglais
avec ce risque d'un royaume désuni vous
l'avez dit monsieur le ministre des
Affaires
étrangères le brexit doit être un choc
et même un électrochoc c'est une
évidence pas pour punir pas pour punir
nos amis anglais parce qu'on ne punit
pas mes chers collègues un peuple sous
prétexte que son vote ne nous convient
pas chaque
résultat chaque
résultat Monsieur
H vous le savez de référendum nous
devons les respecter
évidemment un électrochoc bien sûr parce
que ce risque existe et vous savez
d'ouvre ne sera jamais toujours qu'à 35
km de Calais mais un électrochoc pour
l'Europe parce que je pense que c'est la
dernière chance c'est une deuxième
chance mais il n'y aura pas de trè
chance c'est ou la refondation mes chers
collègues ou bien la dislocation et
nimaginez pas un seul instant que le
résultat britannique serait l'expression
d'un particularisme
insulaire
l'euroscepticisme nous concerne
l'institut de sondage européen vient il
y a quelques semaines simplement de
faire une dernière étude sur cet
euroscepticisme le peuple français est
après le peuple grec un des peuples où
leurcepticisme a le plus progressé ces
résultats doivent nous interroger
évidemment et doivent contribuer à
reformuler à refonder une Europe
c'est-à-dire à redonner du sens pour nos
concitoyens pour les peuples européens
pour nos nations européennes redonner du
sens au projets européens redonner du
sens au projets européen c'est redonner
à l'Europe son histoire sa géographie et
une ambition d'abord son histoire il y a
quelques années il y a une dizaine
d'années le nouveau théoricien du djihad
monsieur Abou
mabalsi avait diagnostiqué que l'Europe
était sans doute le ventre mou de
l'Occident et bien l'Europe ne doit pas
être le continent de la
désinification l'Europe doit conserver
son identité l'Europe ne peut pas donner
à chaque peuple le regret d'être
lui-même vous avez dit à peu près la
même phrase monsieur le ministre des
Affaires étrangères
je pense que ce qu'attendent nos
concitoyens et nos peuples c'est la
reconnaissance de ces identités cette
identité qui puise à plusieurs sources
athè bien sûr Rome Jérusalem les
lumières avec la Renaissance ces sources
ces valeurs qui ont défini qui ont
dessiné une conception de l'homme la
lettre au galat une égale dignité
ontologique une conception
de l'homme une conception d'être au
monde aussi qui fait notre civilisation
et bien sûr on a tenté dans les
décennies précédentes de construire
l'Europe par le commerce ça n'a pas
marché par le marché ça n'a pas marché
non plus ni par le droit juron abermas
que vous connaissez philosophe allemand
avait parlé de patriotisme
constitutionnel mais on doit faire
l'Europe aussi par la civilisation ce
doit être un projet de civilisation
l'Europe avec son histoire l'Europe avec
sa
géographie ce qui définit une communauté
politique c'est un territoire il n'y a
aucune communauté politique au monde
sans territoire c'est-à-dire sans
limites sans frontières des frontières
qui disent ce que nous sommes des
frontières qui disent ce que nous ne
sommes pas et vous savez parfaitement
les uns et les autres que les critères
de Copenhague n'ont jamais projeté sur
la carte les limites de ce territoire il
faut bien autre chose évidemment la
carte et le territoire comme aurait pu
écrire Welbeck mais ce que je veux dire
c'est que cette notion de géographie
doit nous inspirer un certain nombre de
réflexe la Turquie n'est pas européenne
le général de Gaulle voulait une Europe
européenne la Turquie est pour 5 % de
son territoire en Europe nous devons
cette clarification aussi bien aux
Européens et nous la devons aussi à nos
amis turcs à ce grand peuple turc en
même temps je le dis et il faut
stabiliser nos frontières bien
évidemment de la bal à la mer ETG les
frontières ne doivent plus évoluer il
faut dire STOP à l'élargissement parce
que cet insertitude géographique à trop
long é été pour l'Europe le symbole le
signe d'une indéfinition de son propre
projet politique une Europe avec son
histoire une Europe avec sa géographie
une Europe aussi avec une nouvelle
ambition en partant d'un diagnostic Sion
n'accepte pas de diagnostic nous
n'aurons pas de bons remè avec un
paradoxe qui est un paradoxe cruel quel
est-il ce paradoxe mes chers collègues
jamais dans leur histoire les peuples
européens n'auront
partagé une telle proximité et jamais
dans son histoire l'Union européenne
n'aura été aussi proche du délitement
quelle est l'origine de ce paradoxe j'en
avance une cause il y a eu une obsession
cette obsession de délégitimer
les étatsntion en ne
proposant comme substitut finalement
qu'une construction
sophistiqué où on a essayé de créer à
tout prix un état hyper centralisé un
état de nature suprantional pourquoi ne
pas le reconnaître mais ce type d'État
ne peut être obtenu qu'avec une
discipline de faire avec toujours plus
de production de normes et de
contraintes et évidemment en tenant les
peuples à l'écart à l'écart de cette
construction les peuples ont eu le
sentiment d'une dépossession et bien je
fais mienne ce qu'a dit le Premier
ministre dimanche à Belleville surmer
lorsqu'il a eu ses mots l'Europe ne peut
pas faire disparaître les États
souverains aujourd'hui le défi que nous
devons relever c'est remettre les
souverainetés nationales les démocraties
nationales au cœur de l'Europe au cœur
du processus pour que les peuples
puissent se réapproprier cette belle
idée européenne dont nous avons besoin
plus qu'hier et sans doute encore plus
demain pour le faire il faut tirer les
conséquences la première conséquence en
terme
d'architecture l'architecture c'est
remettre démocrati nationale ça signifie
que le droit européen ne doit pas être
supérieur à la règle suprême que se sont
donnés les peuples les constitutions
nationales ça signifie que la Cour de
justice ne doit pas se prendre pour une
cour suprême ça signifie que et je
reprends les termes de notre président
qu'il faut remettre dans le processus de
décision les parlements nationaux pour
avoir un continuum démocratique il y a
les procédures de carton orange ou jaune
ça n'est pas suffisant il faudra des
procédures d'un carton vert pour limiter
l'initiative de la Commission pour que
les parlements puissent se réapproprier
cette initiative législative il faudra
sans doute aussi un carton rouge pour
avoir aussi une limite à opposer une
sorte de droit de véau bien sûr et puis
se réapproprier en même temps l'Europe
que nous voulons c'est-à-dire une Europe
que nous allons construire non pas
qu'elle a été construite parce qu'elle a
été construite à juste titre pour mettre
fin à des luttes faticides elle a été
construite finalement pour nous protéger
de nous-mêmes or aujourd'hui le défi que
nous devons relever c'est une Europe que
nous devons construire pour affronter
les déf fis qui viennent de l'extérieur
et il faut répondre à trois défis
d'abord évidemment protéger nos emplois
protéger notre économie avec bien sûr
une stratégie offensive d'investissement
notamment dans la recherche dans le
numérique dans le dans l'énergie aussi
mais défensive parce que quand on a fait
du dogme de la concurrence no faussé ou
du libre échange à tout vent les
horizons indépassables c'était des
naïvetés coupables mes chers collègues
souvenez-vous de chin et Dalcan et ça
n'est pas la première fois que je l'ai
dit ici mes chers collègues à cette
tribune oui chers Jean biset il faudra
un europeéan by Act oui il faut
réintroduire le principe de réciprocité
oui il nous faudra nous appuyer sur une
véritable préférence européenne parce
que sinon nos peuples refuseront
l'Europe que nous voudrions construire
une protection économique une protection
en matière de défense la défense restera
une affaire nationale mais nous devons
approfondir les C opération industrielle
et en même temps budgétaire il n'est pas
normal que la France porte le fardeau de
la défense européenne il faut bien
entendu la partager et enfin les
frontières doivent être défendues
schengun a échoué il faut refonder
shengun frontis doit devenir une
véritable agence avec des gardes de côte
des gardes de frontières sinon nous ne
répondront pas à la crise migratoire
regardons la réalité en face mes chers
collègues et puis bien entendu il faudra
une Europe différenciée avec l'euro
l'euro sans doute il faudra une
gouvernance aussi renforcée une Europe
différenciée avec l'euro mais l'avenir
de l'euro c'est pas tellement un
gouvernement de l'euro c'est d'abord que
chaque pays s'en saisisse et l'avenir de
l'euro c'est la capacité aussi de la
France à tenir ses engagements comme
chaque pays à tenir ses engagements bien
évidemment pour terminer je voudrais
dire et pour conclure en écoutant tout à
l'heure Jeanpierre Farin qui parlait de
l'Europe mortelle Paul Valéri au soir de
la première guerre mondiale avait prédit
que la civilisation était mortelle et
bien oui nous savons désormais aussi que
l'Europe peut-être mortelle et il faut
réagir le monde aujourd'hui ce monde
menaçant ce monde dans dangereux exige
de nous dans ces transformations il
exige une Europe forte dressée devant
les défis et bien mes chers collègues
l'Europe que nous devons faire qui est
d'un cadre naturel de notre action
collective c'est l'Europe des peuples
c'est l'Europe des nations et alors nous
retrouverons le fil de la confiance et
alors l'idéal européen brillera à
nouveau sur notre continent merci
mesdames messieurs les sénateurs je
crois qu'il faut aussi le rappeler que
le Parlement a des pouvoirs qui n'existe
pas toujours vous avez monsieur
retaillot évoqué le carton jaune mais
vous savez que la le Parlement peut
parfaitement se saisir de projets de
directive européennne et dire si ces
directives sont conformes au principe de
subsidiarité donc le Parlement a des
pouvoirs et des droits il doit pouvoir
les utiliser et puis un autre chose que
j'ai entendu de la part de Monsieur
rafarin mais d'autres orateurs l'ont dit
aussi sur les bancs de la droite et de
la gauche et du centre c'est qu' on ne
peut pas faire de l'Europe le Bou
émissaire de toutes les décisions que
nous prenons il est parfois facile
lorsqu'une décision est impopulaire de
dire c'est l'Europe qui nous l'impose je
dis à Monsieur Laurent c'est pas
l'Europe qui impose de faire telle ou
telle réforme c'est la France c'est
chaque pays qui décide de légiférer sur
son droit du travail s'il le souhaite de
réformer ses retraites s'il le souhaite
mais n'allons pas chercher toujours la
responsabilité ailleurs assumons nos
propres responsabilités ce qui n'empêche
pas après le débat démocratique d'avoir
le dans nos instances dans notre
Parlement dans la société française mais
je crois que si on tient ce discours il
y a un danger c'est de faire porter à
l'Europe toutes les responsabilités des
problèmes que les Français connaissent
et ça fait mon l'uroscepticisme et à mon
avis c'est pas rendre service à l'Europe
je voulais simplement vous faire part de
ce sentiment mais audelà de ça audelà de
ça je crois que il y a deux sujets en
fait qui sont deux questions qui sont
devant nous je sais que j'ai peu de
temps monsieur le Président donc je vais
très court il y a deux sujets qui sont
devant nous essentiels c'est comment
géronsnous la situation de crise dans
laquelle nous trouvons après le vote du
peuple britannique que faisons-nous que
fait l'Europe je crois que plus
l'incertitude demeurera plus la
confusion s'installera et plus le peuple
britannique comme les peuples européens
seront pénalisés les conséquences
financières nous les voyons déjà mais
les conséquences économiques certains
parlent déjà d'auben mais attendez avant
de parler d'auben quelles seront les
conséquences pour la croissance pas
seulement en Grande-Bretagne mais aussi
en France en Europe et de tous mes
échanges de tous mes contacts que j'ai
eu depuis depuis vendredi matin c'est
clair que tout le monde est en angoisser
à cette idée et que la nécessité que les
27 qui vont avoir à discuter et à
négocier avec la Grande-Bretagne soient
uni et reste uni pour garder l'essentiel
alors je peux vous dire que ça traverse
l'esprit de tous et qu'il faut y
travailler donc à la fois il est
important qu'il y ait des concertation
et en particulier entre la France et
l'Allemagne avec évidemment d'autres
pays ce n'est pas exclusif mais il faut
aussi préserver cette unité à 27 qui
pourrait aujourd'hui être fragilisé donc
laisser durer les choses comme certains
le préconisent dans la relation avec la
Grande-Bretagne après le vote populaire
de de jeudi c'est prendre une lourde
responsabilité avec des conséquences
financières économiques et politiques à
la fois pour l'Europe en tant que projet
et en tant qu'avenir mais aussi pour la
Grande-Bretagne elle-même et donc c'est
vrai qu'on ne peut pas être indifférent
au débat public qui se passe en
Grande-Bretagne c'est pas faire de
l'ingérence c'est constater deux choses
c'est que ce référendum n'a pas été
organisé pour une autre raison que pour
régler un problème interne à une
formation politique et c'est d'avoir
pris une très lourde responsabilité
d'avoir mis le Royaume-Uni dans cette
difficulté mais l'Europe
aussi
alors le vote a eu lieu donc il s'agit
pas de le contester on voit ici ou là
des gens qui disent il y a qu'à
recommencer mais on va pas ça déjà eu
lieu c'est insultant c'est insultant
pour les peuples c'est insultant pour la
démocratie donc respect du vote
populaire britannique oui ça doit être
la position
éne la nôre mais c'est aussi de la part
des Britanniques le respect de ce que
nous sommes et le respect de ce que nous
voulons faire ensemble plutôt l'article
50 qui ne règle pas tout mais qui est le
seul cadre légal auquel nous devons nous
référer nous pvons nous référ plutôt il
aura été mis en vre mieux ça sera dans
l'intérêt de tous et il s'agit pas de
punir monsieur Laur pourquoi punir le
peuple a décidé mais il s'agit d'assumer
de respecter ce qui a été voulu
c'est-à-dire la sortie de l'Union
européenne et donc cette sortie de
l'Union européenne une fois l'article 50
engagé alors il faudra l'organiser de
façon maîtrisée responsable sérieuse
honnête mais effectivement demain dans
le cadre de cet article du traité et
bien la Grande-Bretagne devient un
pays-tiers mais entre un pays-tiers et
l'Union européenne et bien il y a des
relations à construire des relations
économiques des relations commerciales
des relations financières mais avec des
règles qui sont pas les mêmes que celles
de l'appartenance et la question de la
libre circulation des personnes c'était
justement ce qui était contesté par les
partisans du brexit donc il faut bien
aller jusqu'au bout de la logique et
pourquoi il faut aussi aller vite et là
je suis surpris de l'attitude de
certains dirigeants et qui ont porté la
campagne du brexit ils n'ont rien prévu
ils n'ont rien proposé ils n'ont rien
préparé pour en prenant ce risque
d'entraîner le peuple britannique et en
disant des choses inexactes je pense à
ce dirigeant d'un parti nationaliste et
populiste dont on a le correspondant en
France Monsieur farad qui avoue qu'il a
menti le lendemain de l'élection
lorsqu'il dit aux électeurs britanniques
vous savez si nous sortons de l'Europe
alors nous n'aurons plus à payer la
cotisation que nous payons à l'Union
européenne et avec cet argent nous
pourrons l'investir dans les hôpitaux et
là des électeurs se sont retrouvés comme
grogy lorsque Monsieur farrage a dit oui
mais enfin c'est pas tout à fait exact
lorsqu'il y aura un accord et il faudra
qu'il y en ait 1 entre l'Union
européenne et la Grande-Bretagne il y
aura quand même un financement que nous
devrons assurer le montant c'est la
négociation mais en tout cas ce qui
avait été dit était faux et les
électeurs ont été trompés mais peut-être
mais maintenant le vote est là alors il
faut aller jusqu'au bout de cette
logique et le faire de façon responsable
et respectueuse et c'est donc
l'importance de cette décision qui sera
prise demain et après-demain la cohésion
la solidarité et le respect entre les 27
la deuxè question vous l'avez tous
évoqué fortement c'est quel avenir pour
l'Union
européenne les arguments ont été dits et
je les reprends pas je les av moimême
rapportés dans l'intervention liminaire
je crois qu'en effet dans ce nouveau
monde dans lequel nous sommes entrés
déjà depuis longtemps et qui se dessine
de plus en plus comme un changement
profond et qui trouble les peuples qui
les angoissent qui les intièent qui est
celui de cette nouvelle donne globalisé
où les modèles les modèles de société
les modes de vie peuvent être mis en
péril que allons qu'allons-nous devenir
que vont nous vont devenir nos emplois
quel avenir pour la jeunesse mais aussi
nos modèles sociaux nos modes de vie et
de culture c'est ça qui est en jeu qui
angoisse les peuples et pour autant de
grandes puissances de grandes forces
s'organisent la Chine l'Inde et les
États-Unis qui demeurent comme la grande
puissance mondiale mais la Russie qui
veut redevenir aussi cette puissance
l'Afrique qui devant nous avant d'être
une grande puissance est un défi qui est
celui de sa sécurité et de son
développement qui peut répondre à ça qui
peut répondre en apportant au peuple
européen la conviction qu'ils vont
pouvoir avoir un avenir dans ce monde
globalisé et inctains et en même temps
qu'on leur assure leur sécurité à
l'intérieur des frontières leur sécurité
à l'extérieur des frontières et en même
temps la protection d'un certain mode de
vie si nous ne voulons pas si nous
voulons laisser tomber les peuples
européen alors nous pourrons défendre la
cause qui est seulement le retour aux
frontières et au sol nation mais si
voulons les défendre et les entraîner
avec vous avec nous alors il faudra
revenir à l'esprit des pères fondateurs
et pas dénigrer ce qui a été fait depuis
60 ans et que nous allons commémorer
l'année prochaine mais dont il faut se
servir comme levier pour retrouver la
source pour retrouver le sens pour
retrouver la force et bien c'est ce que
nous avons à faire maintenant ensemble
et donc ça se prépare ça s'improvise pas
par des slogans voilà Mesdames et
Messieurs les Sénateurs ce que je
voulais vous dire en quelque sorte le
travail sur ces deux sujets commence
mais faisons-le en responsabilité et
plus nous le ferons en responsabilité et
en sincérité plus nous serons respectés
par les citoyens les citoyennes
européens qui aujourd'hui sont inquiets
et angoissés je rencontrai hier je l'ai
dit les pays de visegrade et il y avait
là parmi eux le ministre des affffaires
étrangères de Slovaquie qui vendredi
prochain 1er juillet avec son pays il va
présider l'Union européenne pendant 6
mois je peux vous dire qu'il avait la
gravité dans ses propos le poids sur ses
épaules car il sent qu'il va se jouer
quelque chose d'essentiel mais en même
temps même si nous avons des différences
et des divergences je me suis rendu à à
varsovi et je m'en suis rendu compte il
y a quand même quelque chose que nous
avons en commun et qu'il faut sans cesse
rappeler c'est qu'après l'appel de
Schumann en 1950 dont le portrait est
présent dans le salon de l'horloge du
quai d'orset et que je croise chaque
jour il y a eu là un acte historique qui
a permis d'entraîner l'Allemagne dans ce
début de construction européenne pour
enfin mettre fin à la guerre c'était la
Communauté européenne du charbon et de
l'acier après il y a eu d'autres
tentatives il y a eu la CED qui a échoué
il y a eu la conférence de Messine c'est
vrai il y a eu le traité de Rome Maurice
fort a été cité par Jacques mzard tout à
l'heure et il avait raison mais il y a
eu aussi cette étape extraordinaire que
les peuples concernés n'oublient pas
c'est que c'est l'Europe qui a permis à
ses peuples l'Espagne de sortir du
franquisme au Portugal de sortir de la
dictature de Salazar et aux Grecs de
sortir de la dictature des
colonel et que et
qu'ensuite après la chute du mur de
Berlin et la réunification de
l'Allemagne c'est tous ces pays qui ont
été pendant si longtemps sous le jou de
la dictature soviétique qu'il soit
d'Europe centrale ou qu' soit d'Europe
de l'Est il voit aujourd'hui dans
l'Europe même si parfois encore une fois
nous pouvons les critiquer sur certaines
de leur positions il voi dans l'Europe
la liberté la démocratie la paix alors
c'est à nous avec eux de construire la
suite de l'histoire européenne c'est
notre responsabilité nous le devons aux
françaises et aux Français et aux
citoyennes et aux citoyens européens et
d'abord mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs à la jeunesse
merci
merci merci monsieur le ministre voilà
vous avez donc pu suivre les débats au
Sénat au lendemain de l'annonce du
référendum britannique un choc qui
bouleverse les fondements même du projet
européen vous pouvez revoir bien sûr ce
programme sur notre site internet
publicsenatfr très bonne suite de
programme sur notre
antenne y